bonjour monsieur lapointe
alors on peut dire que c'est un début
peut-être même un bon début mais ce sont
des amendes pour 6 seulement des 154
passagers est ce que vous espérez qui en
est d'autres qui leur sont imposées
tout à fait avec les vidéos qu'on a pu
voir qu'ils ont été placés par eux-mêmes
sur les médias sociaux on voit qu'il y a
des comportements beaucoup plus
dangereux que de ne pas avoir rapporté
vous d'avoir triché leur passeport
vaccinale à propos de l'aco vide et
lorsqu on amène de sa propre boisson
qu'on fume dans un avion qu'on ne suit
pas les consignes qui sont demandées par
les agents de bord alors on est la
sécurité des passagers et des membres
d'équipage alors oui on espère qu'il y
aura d'autres autrement c'est ça vous
faites référence évidemment à ces
comportements qu'on continue de voir
c'est à dire dans ces se tenir debout
sur un siège fut mis ça c'est interdit
aussi en vertu de la loi sur
l'aéronautique
mais pourquoi est-ce que c'est dangereux
de boire ou même de vapoter dans un
avion vous savoir madame riche et dans
un premier temps que quand d'une
consommation à bord d'un avion qui vole
à 35 maîtrise et souvent l'équivalent de
deux verres de boisson pris au sol donc
on synthétique beaucoup plus rapidement
et c'est pour ça qu'on demande aux
passagers de ne pas apporter leurs
propres boissons pour que les agents de
bord plus garder un certain contrôle
dans la cabine il faut savoir que
n'importe quel être humain qui
consomment beaucoup vont perdre ses
inhibitions et sa capacité de suivre des
consignes alors souvent par delà la
cigarette électronique on a eu dans le
passé des gens qui allaient dans les
toilettes mixtes allumer des cigarettes
mais c'est extrêmement dangereux un
passage intoxiquées lors de ma carrière
j'en ai vu que ce sont des habitants des
à lyon il y en a qui ont amorcé des
batailles il y en a qui ont essayé
d'ouvrir des portes de passagers ou des
sorties sécurité alors c'est extrêmement
dangereux oui on peut imaginer en effet
là évidemment on ne connaît pas le
montant exact des amendes qui ont été
imposées décerné à ses passagers et on
peut se demander est-ce que l'effet
dissuasif sera suffisant bien par delà
l'aspect monétaire moi j'ose espérer que
il y aura éventuellement une liste qui
empêchera ces gens là ces délinquants
pour pour ne pas avoir la capacité de
voler sur des sociétés im quel que soit
ou au canada des sociétés canadiennes et
il nous sommes très contents les membres
de l'aviation de voir que les médias
font un suivi comme vous faites ce soir
pour que le grand public soit au courant
que le transport canada la france est
mauvaise ou très mauvaise et très au
sérieux oui alors vous parlez de 7 cette
liste qui n'existe pas encore la no fly
list la liste qui interdit à des gens de
monter à bord d'avions mais les amendes
le lisent les les amendements qui ont
été
décernés comment est-ce que ces reçus
comment est-ce que c'est perçu par les
gens de l'industrie est ce que les
agents de bord se sentent rassurés con
qu'on encadre un peu mieux les
délinquants bien je pense qu'il faut
dire dans un certain sens merci à la
pandémie parce que nous pauvres agents
pas soit n'importe où sur la planète
avec l'arrivée d'une masse que pendant
les vols c'est extrêmement difficile
pour toute société aérienne et surtout
les agents de bord de faire respecter le
port du masque et je pense que la
pandémie pour la première fois au permis
au ministère des transports de saisir la
difficulté qu'ont les agents de bord de
faire respecter des consignes et il
semble qu'avec suffisamment globe qu'il
y ait un travail qui se fait une
synergie derrière les portes closes
entre les sociétés aériennes et
transports canada alors je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui que on espère qu'il y
en aura d'autres mais on est très
satisfait du travail de transports
canada ce moment ce bon monsieur
lapointe qui a un transporteur aérien
dalton qui demandent qui est une une
liste d'une no fly list justement des
gens qui ne pourraient plus embarquer à
bord des avions est ce que vous pensez
qu'on en arriverait là
chaque société aérienne d'envergure et
c'est à son propre système de sécurité
interne suspense air canada par exemple
il y a déjà des passagers qui sont
empêchés de voler ce qu'on souhaite tous
que delta souhaite c'est que c'est cette
liste ne soit partagé entre les
différents transporteurs donc par une
agence commune comme transports canada
par exemple si on bénissait un passager
sur sunwing peut-être le principal
donateur pourrait éventuellement faire
partager la liste de ces gens engagent
n'y ait que air canada où wall street
par exemple soient au courant que
quelqu'un est bannie sur
cette voie là pour que toutes les
compagnies aériennes soient vraiment au
même niveau alors on verra bien comment
tout ça évolue jean lapointe merci
beaucoup pour cette entrevue toujours
plaisir à voir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]